that if you really enjoy eating potato
chips and if you struggle to stick to
the serving size and the nutrition label
then you are an addict and of course
everybody struggles with that because
frankly the serving sizes are a joke if
you look on the back of your bag of Laz
barbecue chips it will tell you that the
suggested serving size is like one chip
per person per week but if you struggle
to keep your consumption down to that
level you might as well be shooting up
heroin according to the science the New
York Post reports the news with this
headline quote ice cream and potato
chips are just as addictive cocaine or
heroin research that's according to
research research says that